hey guys how's it going it's Justine
bolkcom back to my kitchen we are
celebrating the holidays and we are
getting so festive here that I just
can't even contain myself
the first thing that we're gonna be
making we're making two things today but
the first one is gonna be a peppermint
plate when I first saw this I thought
wow this is everything that I've always
wanted a peppermint plate it's not
really what I thought but anyway we're
gonna make it cuz it looks cool and then
double I'm talking more peppermint plate
eyes all these cute little Christmas
treat cones but I think that there might
be a problem with that but we'll address
the problem when we get to the problem
first things first pre-heat your oven to
get yourself a round pan like this cover
it in parchment paper because we're
gonna be melting our little peppermints
which we've unwrapped and took a really
long time so that was fun we didn't want
to be sitting here for 20 minutes going
like this we also have some white
chocolate over here melting in our
little melting pot so that's gonna be
used for our little Christmas trees so
these are the things that we're gonna
need for our Christmas trees ice cream
cones the white chocolate chips that are
currently melting here we don't need
those anymore some sprinkles a variety
of sprinkles that's it and they all need
these either I also got some coconut
flakes so let's start with the
peppermint plate let's put our little
peppermints into this pan and you just
want to place them all around pretty
evenly there will be space in between
them but it's gonna melt down
everything's gonna work out this feels
like that block thing that you just
what's like a jigsaw it what's in it
real big scute yes that's what this
feels like you don't know if I like that
cool I've bought this in the oven for a
five to eight minutes it says but I
don't even know if I should believe that
or not because I've never done this
before
and I don't know what
doing so I'm gonna check it every two
minutes hot so now we've got our
government's in the oven we're going to
work on our little trees that are going
to decorate the top of it here's the
issue the cones that I bought our waffle
cones and if what's inside this package
looks like this these are not gonna
stand up on their own because it's not
even so mistakes were made
okay see that it's not gonna stand up so
what you could do is just get the right
cones to begin with and you don't have
to do this but I screwed up oh yeah that
looks good Merry Christmas Happy
Holidays would you get under the tree
nothing fail I got a fail box of cold
well this one looks like it's gonna be
an igloo oh god that's a great idea
oh my God why are ours into that you
could just eat your way around and
they're brilliant nice buddy
so first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna paint our beautiful trees and
here's something that I also realized
that I just messed up is I put some oil
flakes into my chocolate chips to make
the chocolate thinner it's a little bit
too thin now so now this is what we're
dealing with we're dealing with some
very thin chocolate I'm just gonna keep
piling this on
I feel defeated look at them they're
edible I thought I'd look like not real
these are so pretty
holy crap this is like the coolest thing
that I've ever ever used well now I
don't have any left they said they're
edible
gosh I love the holidays
I'm feeling very festive now I'm gonna
put on some of these little balls
holiday balls Oh everything he hate
Pinterest cuz everybody's like welcoming
and I'm over here like look at me it's
cool there's our holiday ball Wow look
at these okay yep they're starting to
bubble look at that do you see that so
let's take some of our coconut flakes
I've never really used with coconut
flakes for anything before so don't
really know how to really work with them
like oh I think they need some color we
need some color to liven up this tree
shout everything is in failure but don't
let that discourage you success comes in
many packages some just look like crap
hey everyone welcome back to several
hours later this is what we're left with
everything looks really nice looks great
we've got our trees they also look
mediocre here's something that I learned
in my several hour off time while
shooting other videos there's a
difference between wax paper and
parchment paper and I use wax paper it
says right here wax paper is microwave
safe it says here
parchment paper is oven safe and
nonstick where's the memo in my feeble
small tiny non-existent mind the wax
paper wouldn't melt to the side of the
pan but we're still gonna try to salvage
this I'm a little bit sad because I
really thought this was gonna be a great
holiday treat for my friends hate you
just see what we're working with I mean
the wax has melted on to the candy oh
[Music]
it's Rizzoli it's turning look it's
turning you can do it you can do it I
mean this thing is definitely completely
shattered but if we keep the wax paper
on it no one will ever know except me
and you this can just be our little
secret I think it looks quite excellent
so now we've got this going we're gonna
put our little little tree toppers on it
Wow I'm speechless
well guys here you have it it's the
peppermint placed Christmas tree miracle
mistake I tried I really tried I hope
you guys enjoyed this video and I hope
that gave you some inspiration for some
holiday DIY art craft baking ideas of
your own as always don't follow my
directions learn from my mistakes make
yourself better happy holidays
I'll see you guys soon thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe
because that would be a really great
Christmas present that's the best gift
that you could give a youtuber see you
later if your head doesn't fit
oh sorry I'm so sorry I thought how to
handle on that and I cannot I did not
have a handle on that
oh my god